du soir et là exclu pour TPMP à 20h52
puisque on va revenir sur le drame de
crepol on se rappelle un Thomas 16 ans
d'ailleurs CIT son anniversaire il aur
eu 17 ans exactement qui a été poignardé
alors pourquoi ils m'ont alors à la
sortie d'une fête de village neuf
suspect ont été interpellés et
rapidement ce drame a pris une dimension
politique vous l'avez vu et ce soir on a
maître Romaric château avocat de l'un
des suspect qui vient nous voir qui va
nous donner sa version euh pourrait bien
sûr lui dire que dire ce que vous pensez
hein et puis il y a Reda aussi qui va
venir nous voir vous savez Reda
connaissez Reda notre ami Béage
porte-paroleunité SGP Police île- de
France parce que il a des infos comment
les identités et adresses des suspects
ont-elles pu être rendu publ ça il va
nous dire comment par ça c'était c'était
un gros sujet regardez petit récap ils
sont avec nous ça c'est du lour c'est
parti il y a un peu plus de de semaines
la France découvrait avec effroid le
meurtre de Thomas saison tué alors qu'il
était à une fête de village c'est un
gamin très très très gentil et tandis
que de nouvelles révélations ont été
dévoilées pour tenter d'expliquer
comment cette soirée a viré au drame et
donc il y a un Thomas L qui aurait
agressé un des gars de la cité parce
qu'il av les cheveux longs il tiré les
cheveux une enquête a été ouverte après
la diffusion des noms de plusieurs
suspects sur les réseaux sociaux au
total neu personnes ont récemment été
mises en examen dans cette affaire nous
souhaitons effectivement que le coupable
soit démasqué le plus rapidement
possible meurtre de thomasp l'avocat de
l'un des suspect s'exprime ce soir dans
TPMP merci Maître romain RIC château
d'être avec nous merci beaucoup d'être
là c'est important pour nous de vous
avoir on entend tellement de choses on
aimerait avoir votre version également
Reda Béage porte-parole unité HP police
î-defance on a des questions poser Redda
merci d'être là comment les identités
adressent des suspects déjà son peut
être rend public alors je peux pas vous
donner la j'ai pas la réponse mais j'ai
il y a des éventualités soit des
journalistes qui ont eu par leur réseau
parce que vous savez qu' il y a des
journalistes qui sont proches des
services de police ou de gendarmerie
soit via le parquet soit comme on
discutait en coulisse m'a dit que non
mais moi les avocats aussi ont accès au
dossier apparemment là c'était avant
l'accès au dossier mais en tout cas il y
a pas forcément c'est pas forcément les
forces de l'ordre qui ont accès ou qui
ont pu communiquer en tout pas eu
forcément violation du sécret de de
l'enquête par certains policiers end pas
forcément et surtout que là on parle de
policier et l'enquête a été confiée à la
gendarmerie pour leil g red une des
hypothèses quand même c'est une fuite
des enquêteurs envers potentiellement un
ou des influenceurs ou réseau d'extrême
droite qui après aurait utilisé ça donc
il est très possible quand même qu'à
l'origine un de vos collègues ou un
gendarme soit l'auteur de la fuite c'est
possible mais comme vous dites c'est
éventualité toujours pareil il faut
attendre l'enquête en France on vient je
viens souvent sur ce plateau les gens
veulent tout de suite les réponses
veulent tout de suite comprendre mais
c'est très difficile en fait et des fois
on condamne des fois aussi tout de suite
soit les auteurs présumés soit euh des
fois il y a des victimes présumées ce
qui est pas le cas de crpol mais voilà
crpol les versions changent mais en même
temps c'est très médiatisé chaque médiia
des fois une version différente nous les
policiers on est là ou les gendarmes on
est là juste pour faire notre job
essayer de faire avancer l'enquête au
maximum ex voilà pour vousz quelque
chose ajouter non mais c'est vrai que
c'est la grosse interrogation parce que
je vois arrêun sourire c'est V c'est
vrai que ça aurait pu être extrêmement
dangereux je sais pas si maître est
d'accord avec moi mais ça aurait pu être
extrêmement dangereux que que des que
des noms fuitees des noms de mineurs il
y aurait pu avoir une une vendétat après
ils auraient pu être menacés il faut en
tout cas que l'enquête montre exactement
le mécanisme de la fite il va y avoir
une enquête ouais symboliquement parlant
je pense qu'il est important de
souligner que quand les l'ultra droite
pardon a fait cette manifestation qui
n'était pas autorisée il y a eu des
affrontements avec les forces de l'ordre
il y a eu cinq policiers qui ont été
blessés et qui a empêché ces individus
de rentrer avec des barres de fer et des
battes de baseball dans la cité de la
monnaie pour en découdre avec les jeunes
vous merci les policiers hein voilà bien
sûr c'est quoi cette histoire cette
histoire là euh actuellement une
centaine de policiers sont surveillés
par la dchsi à cause de leur penchant
vers l'ultr droite ben écoutez ça il y a
une enquête qui est en cours je peux pas
je travaille pas pour eux je travaille
pas pour ce ce média là en tout cas mais
comme je le dis souvent la police est à
l'image de sa société vous avez des gens
qui ont peut-être certaines idées et qui
font partie de réseau ultra droite comme
ultra gauche ou autres mais euh pour
nous si c'est le cas je dis bien si
c'est le cas euh bah ils son sont ils
sont poursuivis administrativement
toutes les semaines nous organisation
syndicale on siège à des conseils de
discipline et en général les gens qui
communiquent sur des plaques
d'immatriculation par exemple qui
communiquent avec des garages ou des
fois des gens encore plus mal
intentionnés et ben ils sont sanctionn
voir révoquer toutes les semaines alors
euh Reda avant qu'on entende maître
remomari château avocat de l'un des
suspects des neuf suspects bien sûr qui
ne9 individus qui sont suspectés du côté
de roman sur iser vous la version que
vous avez c'est laquelle non la version
c'est que moi j'ai pas de version
officielle hein vous savez j'ai
découvert comme vous dans les médias ce
qui est ce qui était enfin les faits
qu'on qu'on reproche à une centaine de
collègues apparemment mais moi j'ai pas
de version j'ai pas de de je viens juste
commenter dire qu'aujourd'hui il faut
pas faire une généralité si c'est le cas
et que les policiers sont là pour
protéger les concitoyens français alors
merci d'être avec nous maître romari
château vous êtes donc l'un l'avocat de
l'un des suspects vous pouvez nous
rappeler
vous ce qui s'est passé dans la nuit du
19 du 18 au 19 octobre dernier à crpol
pour vous d'abord deux mots sur la
violation du secret de l'enquête parce
que c'est important bien sûr on sait pas
qui a violé ce secret et il y a une
enquête qui est en cours elle va
peut-être prendre du temps c'est
important de laisser du temps on en
parlera tout à l'heure aux enquêteurs
pour essayer de déterminer l'auteur
d'une infraction ce qui est certain
c'est que cette fuite elle a des
conséquences gravissimes aujourd'hui les
familles des mises en examen sont
menacer il faut savoir que sur les
réseaux sociaux
circule par des centaines des milliers
de personnes s vues les noms les prénoms
les localisations c'est-à-dire les
domiciles les photos les numéros de
téléphone les identifiants X et Facebook
déproche des mises en examen cet
après-midi au cabinet une dame nous
appelle pour nous dire qu'elle voit son
nom sur les réseaux sociaux avec des
menaces attribuées alors qu'elle ne fait
pas partie de la famille d'un des mises
en exam et qu'elle porte le même nom
vous vous rendez compte jusqu'où ça va
donc c'est extrêmement dangereux et donc
il est nécessaire et c'est pour ça qu'on
en parlait dès la semaine dernière et je
suis content que le parquet est ouvert
cette enquête que il y ait une fuite qui
soit identifiée et qu'on sache à quelle
finalité ces informations ont été
divulguées mais ça c'est sur le fond du
dossier bon le fond du dossier je vais
pas moi porter plainte de la main gauche
en vous disant c'est un scandale qu'on
viole le secret de l'enquête pour vous
dire aujourd'hui que je vais violer le
secret de l'instruction donc ce que je
peux vous dire c'est que je défends un
des mises en examen qui conteste avoir
porté un coup de couteau ce soir-là ce
qu'on voit avec l'évolution et le
Parisien je crois l'a très bien dit
c'est que c'est une enquête complexe et
il faut accepter qu'il y ait du temps
nécessaire aux enquêteurs pour savoir
précisément qui a fait quoi et comment
on est pour l'instant à environ 20 jours
des fait l'enquête va durer 18 à 24 mois
bon donc c'est simple il va falloir être
patient oui mais là c'est vrai que tous
les jours euh on en parle et il y a des
gens qui disent que euh voilà il y en a
qui essaient de réécrire l'histoire
queon sait pas trop que Gill on en est
où aujourd'hui après on va poser
d'autres questions quand même à maî
Marie châau c'est sympa alors
aujourd'hui globalement on va dire que
la thèse initiale de l'expédition
punitive comme ça menée contre la soirée
elle est battue en brèche par les
premiers témoignage recueilis par les
enquêteurs c'est plutôt une Rix
c'est-à-dire que il y avait une une
soirée donc donc alors on a on a on a
quand même dit ici on est tombé sur tous
les gars qui avaient dit que c'était
nrix
donc vous aujourd'hui pour vous cenric
aujourd'hui non mais oui oui oui oui d'è
on essaie pas de récrire l'histoire
comme l'a
dit d'après tous les d'après tous les
témoignages quand même des enquêteurs il
y a plutôt l'idée d'une d'une fête qui
dégénère avec la présence de jeunes de
roman suriser 4 qui étaiit déjà à
l'intérieur qui était venu pour un avec
un couteau il faut le dire que le vigile
a
dansit dansitur ilivent de l'alcool ça
c'est sûr et ils sont armés non mais
déjà déjà ton histoire excuse-moi
arrêtecout Ding excuse-mo c'est dingue
c'est dingue écoutez excusez-moi
excusez-moi maître mais
excuse-moi excuse-moi une cout des
mecs il rel il relat les fait mais quand
tu relates les fit c'est quand même
curieux d'aller dans une fête de des
quatre dedans déjà un qui veut rentrer
avec un couteau tu vois pour faire la
fête ou je sais pas mais justement
est-ce qu'on essaie pas de récrer
l'histoire non là je pense que là avec
cette version là Cyril quand on dit
qu'ils sont venus avec des couteaux on
est honnête et ils se sont heurtés après
un clash entre deux personnes à
l'intérieur de la soirée ces deux
personnes sont sorties dehors et là les
deux bandes se sont affrontter et ce qui
est vrai c'est que on va dire que les
rugbyman eux se sont batttu avec leurs
points et les jeunes de roman suriser
avait des couteaux et le jeune Thomas a
été poignardé à mort voilà ça ça je
pense que c'est une présentation je sais
pas si maître est d'accord c'est une
présentation c'est factuel de la soirée
mais qui qui n'exonère pas de
responsabilité les jeunes de roman
suriser bon se transporter avec un
couteau c'est un délit donc il y a pas
de débat là-dessus la personne qui est
venue avec un couteau elle doit être
condamné de même la personne qui a porté
le coup mortel ou celle qui a apporté
des coups pour tenter de tuer une
personne elle doit être condamnée aussi
il y a pas de débat là-dessus mais tout
le monde est d'accord tout le monde est
pour la justice la question est savoir
qui a fait quoi précisément bon on a eu
très rapidement dans les médias des
déclarations des politiques qui ont tiré
des conclusions sur un dossier qui est
en cours de construction maître maître
c'est ça le problème si vous voulez
quand on entend aujourd'hui on entend
aujourd'hui des gens alors qu'il y a
quand même un garçon de 17 ans
aujourd'hui c'était son anniversaire
aujourd'hui qui est mort et on entend
aujourd'hui quand j'entends différents
médias excusez-moi de vous dire ça on a
l'impression que c'est Thomas le méchant
dans l'histoire excusez-moi c'est ce que
j'entends-i
ouitousoubl un garçon de 17 ans qui est
mort je suis désolé de vous dire ça
auourdhuendit on était dans l'émotion
dans les de village si les mecs là de
ROM sur é a le une bagarre un coup point
coup de comme il arrive partout dans les
villages chacun rentre chez soi chacun
va dormir ce qui a déconné là c'est les
faet comme nous le disent Gill comme dit
Monsieur l'avocat c'est que des mecs
attendent dans une voiture avec des
armes un qui essaie de rentrer un
couteau tuas des mecs qui se battent
avec des couteaux qui tuent un jeun et
après nous on doit dans
l'émotion le récit de certains médias
excusez-moi je suis désolé on entend
aujourd'hui le récit sur certaines
chaînes et certaines
radios on dirait on dirait que
Thomas c'est de sa faute excusez-moi je
suis désolé moi moi je me mets à la
place des parents de Thomas à qui je
vois à qui je pense très fort tous les
jours en ce moment et vraiment je je
leur redis voilà comme je suis à fond
avec eux moi je vous dis les parents de
Thomas vous rendez compte quand ils
entendent toute la journée les les
chaînes là sur lesquelles on dit c'est
c'est Thomas limite qui étéit qui est le
responsable du du non mais c'est c'est
fou qu on vient avec des armes des armes
des armes blanches et avec une lame de
24 cm c'est qu'on veut en découdre on
veut on veut blesser ou au minima
blesser quelqu'un en tout cas on veut
att ou mais vous voyez vous voyez bien
que c'est pas la même chose de venir
avec avec une lame et c'est prémédité
parce qu'on veut tuer des blancs comme
on a dit au début une expéditionque pour
tuer des blancs c'est pas la même chose
que une bagarre certes avec un couteau
et ça c'est inadmissible et Thomas est
la seule victime dans cette affaire là
juste parce que ça s'est mal passé et
que finalement le mec a été planté
attendez qu'on parce que les mec qui
attendent dehors et C la vérité elle est
peut-être un petit peu entre les deux je
pense que le déroulé des fait il est pas
tout à fait clair on sait pas encore
qu'est-ce qui se passe avec cette cette
fameuse voiture qui Arve après est-ce
que ce sont des gens qui attendaient ou
est-ce qu'on a la certitude maintenant
que il y a il y a pas une un autre
véhicule qui est arrivé un peu plus tard
dans la soirée ce qu'on avait dit au
début
euh il faut accepter ce que je dire
c'est contre l'hypothèse de la bagarre
etpothèse de jeunes qui sont venus à
postériori peut-être que la situation
elle est un peu entre les deux on ne le
sait pas encoreutêtre jdi de conion à
vous apporter la certitude si vous
voulez c'est que la souffrance de la
famille tout le monde la comprend et
l'émotion que vous témoigné chacun
l'entend et c'est normal et personne n'a
dit en tout cas moi j'ai pas entendu que
que Thomas pouvait être coupable de quoi
que soit certains médias c'est devenu
j'ai entendu excusez-moi j'ai entendu
l'édito de Patrick Cohen bontait que lui
qui disait voilà quand écoutes son édito
tu as l'impression qui dit voilà qui qui
qui qui dit voilà c'est Thomas en limite
Thomas voà bien cherché seulement pas
dire ça il a cherch c'est ce qu'
sousentend clairement il dit que c'est
et quand on entend parler de de de Rix
Paron mais on pense à une querelle on
pense à une petite BAGAR on parle d'un
jeune homme qui est mort et et qui a
perdu la vie donc il y a pas de débat
là-dessus et quelqu'un qui vient avec un
couteau à une soirée ça témoigne d'un
caractère prémédité tout de même en tout
cas de non c'est pas nécessairement un
caractère prémédité parce qu'il y a des
gens on les voit on ils sont jugés
chaque semaine au tribunal qui se
promène avec un couteau dans leur
voiture dans leur poche et cetera ils
ont pas forcément l'intention de tuer
c'est pas parce qu'on a un couteau sur
soi qu'on va tuer une personne mais il
faut pas se transporter avec un couteau
on est bien d'accord là-dessus la
question qui se pose et c'est pour ça
qu'il faut être prudent c'est qu'encore
une fois l'enquête elle va être longue
aujourd'hui on a des éléments qui sont
importants le procureur l'a rappelé
c'est les témoignages il a beaucoup de
gens qui ont été auditionnés la
difficulté c'est laquelle c'est que ça
s'est passé à la fin de la soirée 2h du
matin probablement des gens alcoolisés
voilà vous avez compris beaucoup de gens
ont participé à la bagarre donc
évidemment qu'il y a du stress il y a
une situation qui est subjective et donc
il y a pas des témoins extérieurs
sereins calme qui peuvent dire de
manière objective ce qui s'est passé et
donc on a des témoignages
contradictoires c'est ce que N a dit le
procureur de la République ensuite
l'enquête va continuer analyse ADN pour
savoir peut-être qu' y en a qui disent
qu'ils sont pas sur place il l'ADN va
être trouvée à l'inverse peut-être que
des gens aujourd'hui sont mis en examen
on va trouver l'ADN d'autres personnes
qui peut-être sont en fuite ou en tout
cas sont pas identifié il des actes
comme ça qui vont être déterminants pour
comprendre ce qui s'est passé donc il y
a un drame c'est normal qu'on soit tous
émus mais il faut être prudent parce que
pour l'instant l'enquête n'est pas
terminée la plupart des gens qui parlent
du dossier n'ont pas accès au dossier
donc c'est quand même compliqué de
parler d'un livre quand on peut pas
l'ouvrir et donc c'est pour ça qu'il
faut être extrêmement prudent ça
n'enlève rien au caractère dramatique de
ce qui s'est passé gu est-ce que vous
croyez pas que les gens dont parlait
Cyril qui en quelque part minimise
l'effet le font dans un but politique et
en fin de compte ne s'intéresse même pas
à l'affaire mais uniquement pour faire
de la récupération politique ex moi je
suis avocat je suis pas aujourd'hui là
pour faire de la politique mais ce que
je comprends ce que je comprends c'est
que quand j'écoute les uns et les autres
j'apprends plus sur leurs opinions
politiques que sur la réalité du fond du
dossier et donc il y a une
instrumentalisation instrumentalisation
du dossier qui peut être d'un côté et de
l'autre mais en tout cas aujourd'hui il
faut être prudent donc il y a une
enquête et cette enquête elle est plutôt
efficace aujourd'hui vous avez quand
même six personnes qui sont incarcérées
on sait pas combien de personnes avaient
un coup de cout av ont donné av été armé
d'un couteau donc c'est pour ça si vous
voulez que quand je vois notamment les
les manifestations pour la justice dont
on a parlé tout à l'heure à Roman
suriser heureusement les forces de
l'ordre étaient là pour les interpeller
avant que ça vire au drame parce
qu'encore une fois les adresses des
familles sont communiquées par les
réseaux sociaux les familles aujourd'hui
doivent déménager pour être en sécurité
donc on voit bien qu'il y a là si vous
voulez une effervescence qui nuit
complètement au bon déroulé de la
justice donc la justice ben je pense
qu'elle elle avance plutôt favorablement
il y a une enquête qui s'est passée
extrêmement rapidement beaucoup de gens
interpellés déjà beaucoup de gens
auditionné six qui sont mis en examen
trois sous contrôle judiciaire
maintenant il faut être prudent est-ce
que c'est une provocation qui vire au
drame ça semble plutôt être l'hypothèse
pour l'instant privilégiée par le
procureur de la République dans ces dans
cesunication excusez-moi provocation qui
vire au drame là c'est altercation
altercation excusez-moi altercation qui
vire au drame d'accord parce que
provocation non altercation qui vire au
drame alors je précise simplement vous
parliez de mise en examen et Cyril pour
aller dans votre sens quand même hein
les mises en examen c'est meurtre en
bande organisée c'est pas des mises en
examen pour Rix pour ces meurtres en
band organisé V client est-ce qu'il est
mis en examen pour meurtr enandg ceux
qui sont mis en examen sont mis en
examen pour meurtr en band organis
reconnait sa participation au fait il
reconnaît qu'il est sur place lui il a
participé à la soirée il y étit pendant
1 heure 1h3 2 he et on voit bien là
qu'il y a pas de préméditation vous
allez pas une soirée avec votre
téléphone personnel avec le véhicule de
votre maman pendant 1 heure 1 he de pour
danser boire parler non moi mon client
n'a pas de couteau lorsil arrive à la
soirée oui mais c'est pour ça qu'il va
falloir faire le tri si vous voulez
quand j'entends les romanés avec des
couteaux non les romanés pas avec des
couteaux s'il y a une bagarre peut-être
j' j'en ai aucune idée il y a une
altercation il y a une bagarre elle se
généralise l'un d' individus plus bêtees
plus dangereux plus armé que les autres
don un coup de couteau mais les autres
sont pas forcément au courant donc il va
falloir individualiser le rôle de Ch et
on peut pas dire comme ça de manière
globale ah parce qu'ils viennent de la
monnaie parce qu'ils viennent de roman
parce qu'ils sont maghrébins ils ont
forcément un couteau falloir faire le
est-ce qu'au terme de l'enquête vot
clent il a un casier ou oui il a déjà
été condamné jamais pour des faits de
violence il a aussi le bac puisque vous
me posez la question il a également
travailler en tant que frontalier avec
la Suisse pour des infractions routières
donc si vous voulez il faut être prudent
bon si dans 3 mois si dans 6 mois si
dans 3 Mo pouvez dire avec certitude
qu'il y aurait pas de préméditation non
j'ai pas dit avec certitude moi j'ai dit
faut être prent non je dis que mon
client mon c que c'est pas compatible
avec le fait que client était là depuis
1 heure ou 2 heure ça me paraît
compliqué de d'aller à une soirée avec
son téléphone avec son véhicule d'y être
pendant 1 heure 1hure3 à boire à parler
peut-être à danser peut-être à draguer
alors qu'on sait qu'on va tuer quelqu'un
bon moi ça me paraît contradictoire mais
l'enquête on verra ce qu'elle ce qu'elle
démontre moi je vous dis ce que j'en
pense sur des éléments qui me paraissent
plutôt logiques voilà ensuite si dans un
mois si dans 3 mois si dans 6 mois on
apprend que finalement l'auteur du coup
de couteau mortel ne vient pas de la
monnaie ne vient pas de roman mais d'un
village alentour qui s'appelle pas
Mohamed Karim mais Julien au Vincent
qu'est-ce qu'on fait bon et ben on voit
bien qu'on sera allé beaucoup trop vite
en besogne et donc il faut être
extrêmement prudent avant de tirer des
analyses de société on est tous
bouleversés par le drame et c'est pas
parce que je suis avocat d'un mise en
examen que j'ai aucune pensée pour la
famille aujourd'hui mais il faut être
prudent et se dire qu'on a une enquête
qui est en cours de construction et que
il va falloir attendre les
investigations supplémentaires pour
déterminer de manière précise le rôle de
non non mais ce qu'on disait C c'était
pas contre vous on disait aujourd'hui il
y a il y a certains médias quand tu les
écoutes tu as l'impression que Thomas
limite voilà il a il a cherché quoi
c'est un truc de fou d'entendre ça peut
pas entendre ça je suis désolé ont
oublié le drame de la mort de Thomas et
ça ce n'est pas et ils ont oublié
beaucoup de témoignages de gens qui ont
carrément cru que c'était un attentat
tellement c'était violent et ceux qui
attendaient dehors en buvant des des
coups qu'est-ce qu'il demandait à ceux
qui sortaient fumer il demandait si
c'est on était toujours fouillé pour
rentrer pourquoi parce qu'ils avaient
des couteaux et ils attendaient devant
cette ce bal ils venaient pour s'amuser
ces gens-là excusez-moi moi je ne peux
pas entendre qu'il venaient pour voir
des filles parce que c'est ce qui
circule vous venez voir des filles
draguer des filles dans B avec des
couteaux comme ça je suis
désoléintérieur je dis pas il pasé mais
ceux de l'extérieur excusez-moi et quand
on sait qu'ils sont partis en voiture et
que certains et qu'on a entendu des
coups de feu tout ça on l'entend pas
beaucoup excusez-moi donc alors
maintenant bien sûr l'enquête commence
mais il y a des choses qu'on entend
beaucoup et des choses qu'on entend
beaucoup moins donc moi je veux qu'on
entende ces choseslà aussi je suis
désolé ben voilà et ben voilà parce que
moi je lis tout les petites lignes et
tout ça mais si vous écoutez la petite
musique c'est une altercation vous avez
parlé encore une fois de petite musique
c'est la regardez provocation
altercation je suis désolé imaginez le
pauvre jeune homme qui a peut-être c'est
vrai tiré les cheveux de ce c'est une
Rix je suis désolé c'est point contrep
une Rix de qui cette petite musiqueah la
petite musique de justement de des
hommes des politique de de de l'extrême
gauche ça les arrange si c'est que une
Rix excusez-moi et l'extrême droite mais
l'extrême droite
venroce divisé à ce pointl il y a de
camp il y a de
version
quieocation ce que peuvent entendre les
parents de Thomas en ce moment le jour
d'anniversaire mais moi il faut penser
donc il faut être très prudent et il
faut aussi entendre ça parce que le
vigile c'est par il y a eu un mort il y
a eu un Thomas mais il y en a eu un
autre qui a échappé à un coup de couteau
dans la gorge parce que le vigile vous
savez le vigile aé a été blessé à la
main c'est parce que il a mis sa main
devant et on visait sa gorge donc les RX
comme ça excusez-moi les rugbyman une
chose est sûre c'est que aucun n'avait
un couteau ça on en est sûr donc voilà
donc moi je pense qu'il faut rétablir
les choses et ce qui est terrible dans
le récite c'est certains médias auquel
vous faites référence c'est les raisons
entre guillemets l'explication de
l'altercation on raconte dans cette
édito que tout serait parti d'une
chanson de Jul Chikita et que Thomas
aurait traité l'un de Chikita et donc
que ça expliquerit ce qui s
passé
déclenché moment
explique aucun moment en fait personne
n'a dit mais j a jamais de bonne raison
de se battre il a jamais de bonne raison
de donner un coup de Coutau à un autre
donc ça à qui personne pe penser
cont pourquoi mettre en avant ce genre
de détail complètement inutile comme si
ça justifiait presque ce qui s non pas
du tout c'est pour dire qu'il y a pas de
préméditation que il y a pas des gens
qui sont allés là-bas pour tuer et que
c'est parce qu'à un moment comme ça
arrive souvent on l'a vu au 14 juillet
on le voit dans des fêtes de village on
le voit dans les ferrias on le voit
entre supporters que l'alcool les gos
les égos froissés et ben vite on arrive
au coup de point et parfois au coup de
couteau merci non juste qu'on veut ce
qu'on veut dire aussi ce qui c'est moi
pour moi ceux qui ont tort c'est ceux
qui avaient les couteaux si ça avait été
les rugbyman qui avaient eu les couteaux
pour moi cé
et et aujourd'hui c'est Thomas qui est
mort aujourd'hui je suis désolé voilà
donc on vient pas avec une soirée avec
des couteaux c'est tout il y a pas de
voilà il y a même pas de débat pour moi
c'est c'est vraiment c'est c'est c'est
il faut s'arrêter là et terminer en tout
cas on pense fort à la famille de Thomas
que c'est son anniversaire aujourd'hui
merci en tout cas maîre merci merci à
tous tout de suite mon jeille sur C